UNLIKE RICK WILSON.
HANSON IS A FELLOW AT THE
HOOVER INSTITUTION AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON.
I KEEP NOTICING THE PHENOMENAL
WHERE THE FARTHER BEHIND
MIDDLE AMERICA, RURAL AMERICA
FALLS, THE LONGER, YOU KNOW,
THE DEATH RATE CONTINUES TO
RISE.
THE LIFE EXPECTANCY IS
EXPECTED TO FALL.
THE MORE THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
HATE RURAL AMERICA, THEY HATE
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING
THE MOST.
WHY IS THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M SPEAKING FROM RURAL
AMERICA AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IT'S PHENOMENAL WHEN YOU
SEE CONCRETE EVIDENCE AND THE
EMPIRICAL FASHION OR WHEN YOU
HAVE THE 3% ANNUAL G.D.P.
GROWTH OR THE RECORD LOW
PEACETIME UNEMPLOYMENT OR
300,000 JOBS CREATED IN A
YEAR.
MORAL ACT, TUCKER.
LATINO POPULATION, I LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY THAT IS 90% LATINO.
AT THE RECORD LOWS.
YOU CAN SEE IT.
PEOPLE ARE WORK AND THEY HAVE
MORE DISPOSABLE INCOME.
RATHER THAN FIXATE ON THAT OR
CRITIQUE IT, WE GET BACK TO
NOT ONLY IS TRUMP A NAZI, BOTH
OF THE CLIP THAT THE SPEAKERS
CALLED TRUMP AND SUPPORTERS IN
THE PAST NAZI LIKE, BUT THIS
IS AN ATTACK ON PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE PURPOSE
OF THE POLITICALLY CORRECT
MOVEMENT.
YOU DON'T STEREOTYPE AN
INDIVIDUAL DEMONIZING AN
ENTIRE GROUP.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THIS IS
NOT NEW, TUCKER.
ALL WILSON WAS DOING IS
RECHANNELING US THINK HIS NAME
WAS CAPUTO A POLITICAL
REPORTER, THREE OR FOUR MONTHS
AGO THAT WENT TO A RALLY TO
SAY ONE PERSON HAD MORE TEETH
THAN EVERYBODY IN THE RALLY.
YOU REMEMBER PETER STROZK
SAYING HE WENT TO A SOUTHERN
VIRGINIA WALMART AND COULD
SMELL THE TRUMP REPORTER.
THERE IS ANOTHER F.B.I.
REPORTER THAT SAID THE TRUMP
REPORTERS WERE P.O.S.
PIECES OF BLANK.
THIS IS THE UNDERBELLY OF THE
DEPLORABLES, THE IRREDEEMABLE
AND KLINGERS THAT OBAMA AND
CLINTON USED.
IT'S IRONIC BECAUSE THEY ARE
VERY ELITE THEMSELVES.
THEY THINK THAT BY MAKING FUN
OF THE POOR WHITE AND MOSTLY
POOR WHITE WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE, THAT EARNS THEM THEIR
OWN EXEMPTION OF THEIR OWN
PEOPLE.
AND THEY BELIEVE THEY ARE
EXEMPTION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE VICTIM STATUS AND THEY CAN
SAY WHATEVER THEY WANT.
IT'S A SAD COMMENTARY WHEN THE
ENTIRE POLITICAL CORRECT
MOVEMENT WAS DESIGNED TO NOT
USE OFFENSIVE SPEECH AND STAIR
YESTYPE PEOPLE.
TURNS OUT TO BE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE PRINCIPLE BUT POWER
ALL ALONG.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE A
HISTORIAN.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN REVOLUTION
AIMED AT THE PEOPLE BELOW?
ABOUT REVOLUTIONS FROM BELOW
TRYING TO TAKE POWER FROM THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE?
THIS THIS IS LIKE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE SUPPRESSING THE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE POWER.
>> YEAH.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE, WE HAVE
A VERSI ARISTOCRACY.
THEY WORRY THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING RESTLESS.
WE SAW THIS IN FRANCE.
I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND
WHATEVER THEY WERE DOING, THAT
WAS A DEVOTION TO THE
GLOBALIZATION.
OPTIONAL WARS OVERSEAS,
STAGNANT ECONOMY.
THE GREEN INITIATIVE THAT WAS
HURTING PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE HURT BY
IT.
WE CREATED TWO AMERICAS.
ON THE WINNING COAST AND THEY
HAD TO DEVELOP SOME TYPE OF
REASON TO EXPLAIN WHY PEOPLE
IN THE MIDDLE WERE NOT DOING
WELL.
RATHER THAN SAYING THE JOBS
WERE OUTSOURCED OR WE WERE
OFFSHORING OR NEGLECTING THE
MANUFACTURING THEY CAME UP
WITH A SELF-FULFILLING
PROPHECY.
THEY DON'T HAVE TEETH.
THEY STINK.
UNEDUCATED.
WORRY ABOUT THE MANHOOD.
THAT EXPLAINS, YOU KNOW, "A"
TO "Z" WHY THEY ARE NOT DOING
AS WELL AS PEOPLE IN MALIBU OR
THE UPPER WEST SIDE.
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF IT.
THEY'RE HYPOCRITES.
RICK WILSON WENT AROUND IN
2012 IN A RED PICKUP AND
BRAGGED HE CARRIED A KNIFE AND
HE WAS GOING TO CONNECT WITH
THE REAL PEOPLE AND HELP MITT
ROMNEY GET OVER THE ISOLATION
ON WALL STREET.
WHATEVER IF IT PAID BETTER
THEY WOULD DO SOMETHING ELSE.
IF BARACK OBAMA WANTED TO
BUILD A WALL AND HE DID AT ONE
TIME AT DID HILLARY CLINTON
THEY WOULD SAY THE WALL IS THE
GREATEST THING SINCE SLICED
BREAD.
IT'S POLITICAL PROSTITUTION.
IT'S SAD BECAUSE WE HAVE A
REVOLUTIONARY ECONOMIC AND THE
FOREIGN POLICY CYCLE GOING ON
THAT IS HELPING MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
IF THEY DON'T LIKE.
CRITICIZE IT ON THE PRINCIPLE.
TALK ABOUT THE DEBT.
>> Tucker: STOP ATTACKING
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
TOTALLY FINE TO ATTACK
POLITICIANS INCLUDING TRUMP BY
THE WAY.
BUT WHEN YOU TURN AROUND AND
ATTACK TENS OF MILLIONS OF
YOUR OWN COUNTRYMEN, SOMETHING
IS WRONG.
I THINK.